and as we got closer I could see what it
was it was a California gray whale cow
the California gray whale is one of the
largest animals on the planet a fully
grown female known as a cow can easily
weigh up to 35 tons the equivalent of
eleven female African elephants the
barnacle is encrusted on the upper
surface of this creatures head
positively identified it and then when
we got a little closer somebody yelled I
think it was Heidi that first realized
that there were gray whales in the area
which is what had attracted the killer
whales gray whales and killer whales are
not related orcas are in fact a type of
dolphin they are known as killer whales
not because there are ways but because
their whale killers
this was the attack that I never wanted
to see
one organization is specially equipped
to reveal the dark mysteries of Monterey
Bay marine biologist George Matsumoto
had heard of killer whale attacks on
gray whales but even he had never seen
one even here at the research in super
will spend 300 days a year on two
different ships out there we've never
actually observed a killer whale attack
from our vessels up until now reports of
Orca attacks with a stuff of legend
rarely glimpsed even by those who
studied these animals but the mother's
day encounter would provide scientists
with detailed video
most start to finish 10 and 15 18
minutes after Theora and first sighted
the illness
she spotted another body in the water
off the left side look over there in the
midst of the May there was another
and we are told by Heidi that there the
orcas are attacking a great whale and
baby whales have only one infant at a
time judging by the size of this calf it
was around 3 months old
it was nothing anyone to do the
passengers could only watch
in fascination you don't really want to
watch but you have to because you want
to know what's going on
truly this was one of the most powerful
things any of us on board had ever seen
and workers are so
the killer whales were thrashing their
tails at it
killer whales were trying to prevent the
calf from breathing trying to drop
you